what's up guys bang bang There are two
major stories in the Bitcoin Market this
week the first is that silvergate bank
is in big trouble it appears that 1600
clients that all use silvergate are
responsible for about 80 percent of the
fiat currency that flows into the
digital asset ecosystem that is a major
major choke point in this industry now
silvergate has not only seen massive
withdrawals and they've actually
weathered the storm pretty well from an
operational standpoint but now there are
clients dropping them as a vendor left
and right some of that is coming because
of regulatory pressure some of that's
coming because of uncertainty and unease
and some of that is because silvergate
as a publicly traded company has to go
ahead and tell regulators and
shareholders when they need to
reevaluate their business and whether or
not they'll have enough regulatory
Capital now of course silvergate going
down so much from a stock perspective
hurts their investors but there are
bigger concerns here including how much
currency in cap Capital can flow into
the digital asset ecosystem if Silver
Gate is not able to actually service all
those customers and all those investors
that then leads from a negative story
into a positive story which Bitcoin 67
of all Bitcoin in circulation has not
moved in the last 12 months so at the
same time that we've seen massive chaos
all sorts of hedge funds blowing up
companies potential fraud and now we
even have a major financial institution
that is a publicly traded company under
stress we still continue to see
bitcoiners buying and holding Bitcoin
and having no plans to sell it this is a
tale as old as the Bitcoin Market there
are pluses and minuses pros and cons But
ultimately the market is formed by what
happens over the long run and so
regardless of what the week-to-week
narrative ends up being we continue to
see bitcoiners dollar cost averaging and
holding Bitcoin for the long term keep
your eye on what happens to Silver Gate
it would be incredibly difficult to see
that company come under more stress and
ultimately have to shut down or not be
able to service all their clients every
time I've ever interacted with anyone
over at silvergate I found them to be
incredibly Pleasant educated and
intelligent so let's see what happens
but at the same time the underlying
fundamentals of Bitcoin especially the
holder adoption and the long-term
thinking remain intact that's it for
this week and I will see all of you next
Saturday